that Aqua Alpha take one
V6 um listen
buddy you're fired I I know you're not
too familiar with the concept of fire
cuz you live with Sebastian the crab
under the sea is this your national
anthem everything's better down where
it's wetter take it from
me I contribute the might of Atlantis to
the team what about the power of My
Little Pony as long as we're bringing in
[__]
stuff what about the power of
Narnia and that's super helpful cuz
Atlantis is a bunch of [__] I'm
sorry we're from different parts of the
world you're a sky guy I'm a sea guy
we're masters of our own domain didn't
mean to interrupt just ran down to
Costco to get a bucket of your friends
you recognize any of these [__]
yeah that's Steve I hope he died with
honor going to be honest I wasn't
expecting a yes here of all the
fish that I could have bought to make
fun of you I bought one named
Steve that's
Steve okay you went to Costco just to
make fun of me I didn't Alfred did he
doesn't have much to do with his
afternoons it's pretty much wake up give
me a little
[Laughter]
woohoo with the mighty Trident of
Neptune looks like the swizzle stick you
put in an oyster shooter that looks like
John Goodman Fork here's a couple
Trident for you Poland Springs Tri
Trident
three
harvent can we trust him sorry I got
sidetracked I'm so sorry I've been
trying to be culturally polite and
ignore it but you smell like nigiri left
inside of nori left inside of a van left
in the desert of New Mexico for three
nights and no ventilation you smell like
a bait shop down by the Bayou in January
wait that's not a hot
month thank you saltiest Joe Rogan fan
you look like you work in a crystal shop
you can be the stand in for Zack
galanakis if he ever frosts his tips eat
[__] sorry your dick ass scaled scaled
for her pleasure I'm sorry but even even
for me that's over the
line right I'm going to stop you right
there Evan this is just for office use
only that was perfect I can breathe
underwater so you can you know be alive
while you're speaking to fish that's
where those fish are night vision to see
the fish before you talk to him nobody
wants to be an idiot floating around in
a dark ocean talking only to widen and
reveal there's no fish listening that
would be embarrassing a guy talking
underwater is only embarrassing if
there's not a fish to he are you getting
this in an Ideal World you'd fire
yourself L John
[__] all right who's your Nemesis the
Gordon's
fisherman do you not trust him do not
trust the Gordon's
fisherman cuz he killed so many of your
your ex-lovers go 69 a seahorse you
[__]
pervert we're definitely going to use
that I quit sorry to lose you Red
Lobster I'll miss your unlimited bread
sticks go form a Creed cover band even
if you don't have a jellyfish stuck to
you I'd love to take a leak all over
you
[Music]